the new year begins with a host of
foreign policy challenges for a trump
administration already facing an
impeachment battle here at home State
Department correspondent Richardson sets
the table for what could be a very busy
2020 overseas Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo is first trip of the new year
is off the State Department says
monitoring events in Iraq the assault on
the US Embassy in Baghdad will keep the
secretary in Washington I'll make sure
I'm in the right place to ensure that
our people the people the State
Department and Americans are safe and
secure in the Middle East and if that
means I have to change or delay my trip
for a bit that's what I'll do
administration officials blame Iran for
the attack on the embassy compound in
Baghdad and warned the sanctions
campaign they expanded against Iran in
2019 will continue in 2020 Iran is one
of several foreign policy challenges the
Trump administration faces in the new
year the administration says it plans to
build on its successes Democrats say
there's mostly been failure I think the
innate weakness of his foreign policy
which we've seen not just in the Middle
East but in with respect to Russia and
China and certainly North Korea North
Korean dictator Kim jong-un is
threatening to unveil a new strategic
weapon he likes me I like him we get
along he's representing his country I'm
representing my country we have to do
what we have to do Kim says his country
is no longer constrained by his
agreement with the president to halt
nuclear and ballistic missile tests the
u.s. tried unsuccessfully for a
year-and-a-half to get North Korea to
dismantle its weapons Kim now promises
to move even further away from a deal
and while the president says he's ready
to sign phase one of a trade agreement
with China in two weeks at the White
House there are a host of economic and
human rights differences between the two
countries the US has supported democracy
protesters in Hong Kong and has
denounced China's surveillance detention
and re-education of its Weger Muslim
minority and there's the prospect of a
peace deal with the Taliban in
Afghanistan differences or cooperation
with Russia Nicolas maduro's endurance
in Venezuela a Ukraine centered
impeachment trial questions on the u.s.
relations with its oldest European
allies and all else unexpected from
international events or an unpredictable
president rich there's also some tension
with the folks across the street in
Congress and Saudi Arabia yeah certainly
on foreign policy and one of the
hallmarks of the Trump administration
has been a stronger relationship with
Saudi Arabia certainly as a check to
provide a greater check on Iran but
there's a lot that's gone on in that
relationship with Saudi Arabia the
killing of Jamal khashoggi from a while
back and some of the other issues human
rights being an issue the war in Yemen
these are issues that Congress has
started to push back on creating some
tension there as well
richezza thanks very much